so this is uh my best friend KSI and
Logan Paul's Juice drink uh they told me
they sent me cartons of it and they
never did
so we're here gonna just uh
with FaceTime who are you calling okay
sorry
[Music]
hello land Bible it's me tell me we're
going to be reviewing snacks from
England versus the United States of
America is this the same chair Tom
Holland's Got in yes but exactly yeah
yeah still smell like him though so you
still smelly oh my God
here we go
yeah I'm not I think Wilbur really likes
licorice it says a lot about him
can I pour it out yeah I feel like I'm
being quite wasteful
it's so displeased you'll eat them later
promise me 100 promise
I'll find you if you don't eat them I'll
know I'll just I'll be able to smell
them from miles away oh Nate in the bin
oh oh what is that man it just looks
like
it looks like rabbit poop it just
doesn't look great
um well let's now let's lay them all out
so you've got these you've got the uh
the the classic American toxic wastes oh
my God
that was pretty cool did you catch that
on camera clip that that was pretty
exciting
colon
sorry sorry
come back
it's like
sweet spitting like italics it's like
it's just not I think it sounds like a
taste but if the font was like weird and
it was to the slight and you like turned
it down over there it doesn't like it
doesn't bode well these like are sour
like these are I think it says on the
packet
consuming more than one piece at a time
may cause irritation let's eat two and
then sue that Bible
you need help
thank you thank you very much
yeah
let's do two at a time
I have three Yeah well yeah no you're
right one or three
right so I actually in my toxic waste
video I never did more than one and now
I'm doing three this is Extreme all
three of them at once yeah this is so
brave go go
wow
oh wow you know
and yeah I still prefer them
if you want to do it oh oh my God I'm
not prop yeah yeah
oh my God
sending these on eBay half eaten uh
toxic waste
this is an nft
you like to buy these you'll find these
on the live Bible Instagram for eight
hundred dollars I do prefer them though
they have more character they commit to
what they are I appreciate that
oh candy
oh wait
what is beef I've never had beef jerky
this is what like Cowboys eat yeah I'm
never ate oh no oh no but I'm a vegan
which one's British and which ones I
can't I just can't remember he's uh
they're British good I mean they're
humble aren't they you just tell based
on the size of them this is just some
I'm gonna try with the America and you
all know how much I like Americans yeah
not one bit I hate them I hate them so
much
oh my God these things what the [ __ ] am
I allowed to swear yeah yeah throw away
don't eat that
sorry so sorry oh
let's get a zoom on this
that is just that I mean that is just
process that is just the leftover dog
food Mash into it
oh
man
what are you thinking tastes like if
meat was angry at you like a steak has
been like dude why did why well now it's
just treating me wrong can you see why
Cowboys like it no no Cowboys are morons
all right now we're gonna try I missed
it blocky bloody hell original
scratching from an original man have you
heard scratches before well I don't
think so okay we've done great I just
don't get meat snacks let's just all
cook ourselves a nice dinner humble
dinner before bed let's and read the
Bible I don't want this oh what is this
okay that's right
why have you giving me these things
oh Tommy coming out loud Bible dried up
meat you'll love it man get so many
views now dried up meat Jesus Christ
do you like what's the consistency it's
like crackling you're like pork
crackling that your mum gives you but
like
crapper I don't mind them you know I
respect these more at the end of the day
and I've always said this snack Wars is
about respect isn't that right lag Bible
land Bible up
oh
waiting to review this
we're gonna try the America is this
American no for the purposes of this
video Prime is from America because it
started there so let's say oh yes let's
get some hate going all right let's try
this
this is going to be great if I just hate
this this is gonna I and the thing is
I'm a brand I'm a brand I'm a sponsored
eight thousand dollars to say this is
nice
it's quite it's sort of like you can
really taste the americanness of it it's
like Dr Pepper never mind
no but it does taste like this is a a
pungent
I would not I have never drank this if
there's no English
there's Northern bastards mate all right
vimtobe's like fine like a solid like C
out of ten this
here we go so you've never tried Prime
so I have Prime once at my friend's
house and if I say what I thought about
it I'll be sued so
ready everybody I'm gonna be the first
YouTuber that hasn't immediately said he
loves it so this is uh my best friend
KSI and Logan Paul's Juice drink uh they
told me they send me cartons of it and
they never did so
um smells
quite nervous I can see drama in my
hands
um put this
[Music]
it's all right it's not
very carefully wow
[Music]
so we're here I'm gonna just uh do a
face time
thank you
who are you calling well okay sorry
[Music]
you're really embarrassing if he doesn't
answer
any time I'm in snack Wars
this drink sucks
I'm gonna say it you just lost this
drink is fine
prefer Fanta but I prefer it to Dr
Pepper it is I would drink it for free
given it was given to me like it was now
I do not think I would pay what's for
this drink what are you going prevent to
over Prime
that's better than winter
what do I have to
oh
that's enough really that's the American
one yeah are you kidding me and then
that's the British one
all right
oh this is the Great British food this
is how we survived the War I uh I love
my country
foreign
let's try some of this did you like it
no really you have to ask that you
really want to know
let's compare it to uh
cheddar squeeze cheese
oh
I don't really like cheese but
oh that sucks dick
[Applause]
everyone lost that round no points of
work no points for the first time ever
yeah no that was just that was just a
general disappointment in the world yeah
so America won oh God damn I didn't even
realize America could win it was the
first time they've ever won anything uh
yeah I hate to say it but I think
America might have one
um England's still winning my heart but
an American wins in you know no other
factors
that was great yeah you just missed out
on an opportunity there JJ can't keep
that Prime please
oh oh cool so you treated the lands well
but not me yeah I'm starting drama we'll
give you one of every flavor okay put
this on Tick Tock okay
foreign